trong công ty cảnh hơn công việc NAMACB đến hạn mục nhờ gành khách đặt gần bình phần chăm sả trị thực hiện.
Chúng đó, phần xây dựa đặt gần tảm vi phần chăm.
Tâm bộ kết tổ bây tâm của tếp tích tổ thếp mái và cơ lấp mả nhà gà đã hoàn thành.
Cái nhà thầu đứng tập trung hoàn thiện mại kinh lấy sáng, nộ thất và cạnh quan.
Phần đấu các bạn hoàn thành phần xây dựa gà trong đánh chiến.
Lối về thông thiết bị hạn mục quy định việc bật an từ nghiệp xâm bây.
Hãy thông quả li hàng li và săn kết tổ thếp.
Hãy hạn hạn tháng tháng đặt một chương hình chăm.
Thế bị cơ kỹ băng cài cũng đã hoàn thành và đăng được kịp trả trị thực.
Hãy thông xôi chấu hàng li kỳ cười đã được đưa về công trường NAMACB.
Trông tổng sôn NAMACB.
Hãy thông xôi chấu hàng li sẽ cây đưa vận chuyển 2 trong mấy bốn.
Chên 2 trong NAMACB, bài kết bị và đăng tích tục lắm đặt.
Bây kịch đó hệ thống cầu ống lắm.
Hãy thông sẫn đậu tò bài.
Còn các hạn một tháng quảnh tháng mấy và tháng bộ hành cộng năng được đẩn ngang tính tính
nộ đặt đổ nối với trẻ thường.
Theo hà sế vê dự án thình phần bà các công trình thiết yêu hành không.
Đã đàn gần tảm vi phần chăm tổng sả trị hậm đồng đã kỹ.
Nhưng hạn một quảnh trạm như tuyên sau thông kết nối, đường cất hạc cạnh thứ nhất,
đường lăng và sân đỗ tà bài đã cơ bản hoàn thành.
Đường cất hạc cạnh thứ 2, đúng 1 thiện phần biết tông và trường bị là bạc thi bị.
Hãy thống cùng các như liệu hoàn thành người tảm vi phần chăm của lượng công việc.
Theo kế hoạc từ tháng chiến đi tháng 15 năm nay,
xâm bai năm thành sẽ tổ chức bà đợt và năng thủ nghiệp.
Sống sân người đó các đơn vị sẽ bối hợp kìm tra hiệu tròn.
Và hoàn tất cả tụt tục cấp phét, để đưa xâm bây và khai thái thương mại và quay năm hành in không tra me sấu.